I have children who attend schools who
have soccer games y'all you know you all
are asking me as if I'm not a parent in
this city here is Chicago mayor Brandon
Johnson he's very upset because the
guy's under a lot of stress he's got you
know his his citizens are all shooting
each other now you've got these people
coming in and they're kicking people out
of homeless shelters uh and he's got
other problems I have children who
attend schools who have soccer games
y'all you know you all are asking me as
if I'm not a parent in this city I get
it I'm mayor I get it but you're asking
me to give you a date and I have to
court do you understand that you have
not had a mayor like me I get that I
have a wife I have children they have
schedules and plus we still have Public
Safety that we have to address we still
have the UN house that we have to
address I still have a budget that I
have to address and I'm doing all of
that with a black wife raising three
black children on the west side of the
city of Chicago I am going to the Border
as soon as
possible that poor man he's got a black
wife and black children how are we
asking him to have a job at the same
time dude do you know what you signed up
for you're the mayor of Chicago the
place where they kill can we get the
numbers how many people were shot in
Chicago this past weekend we like
getting those numbers you're the mayor
so what you have to take your kid to
soccer I got a black wife well how the
hell do you want me what what you what
do you think I'm doing over here like
okay other people with black wives have
jobs like you got to do your freaking
job but you can see this is it's such a
perfect example of what progressivism
has led itself to right like or what
ultimately leads to which is that you
get a bunch of incompetent buffoons
doing all of the worst things and then
he's also the victim right he's the
victim because he has to take his kid to
soccer and that's a pain in the ass oh
wow low numbers out of Chicago this
weekend only two people were killed in
Chicago this weekend by gunfire only 11
shot that's got to that has got to be an
all-time low that is well I guess he's
doing something when he's taking his kid
to soccer apparently that's
nice